[Music]
i have a visual on the target
response unit conrad i'm listening
i need one man and one young woman go
call for alarm no reason to use weapons
sir
get your goddamn guns down major on the
double objects are unarmed
no hostile intent stand down captain now
[Music]
repeat the order what's going on with
you i said stand down
jesus christ do not use any goddamn
unit is forced to foreign down objects
to be eliminated out of the way
open the gates
ruby we have to go
[Music]
we're going in we're coming in
we must go to the river
so
oh
alpha center 2.0 report
[Music]
they just launched a missile
[Music]
target has been eliminated eliminated
it's off the radar sir
call the goddamn tactical unit i don't
give a damn what channel
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
julia can you tell me why you decided to
help the alien
at what point did you start having
feelings for him
do i have to answer they're back again
you you're in danger
you all went too far in your research we
have to get out of here
you can come back
but she must be eliminated so this is a
cyber attack but not from this planet
you know i don't belong here dad
everything's gonna be fine
i don't even have a passport are we
gonna cross the border we'll have to
cook up a corruption scam
no more cell phones no more digital
[Music]
technology
[Music]
help me
[Music]
[Music]
you